foreign
are you the one that made it
yes I am 8 618 days sober
congratulations
wow but it's hard knowing that I am the
only
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney's show
we're talking to real people who are
experiencing life the UPS the Downs The
Good the Bad and they are trying to
figure out what to do next and on this
show we walk alongside each other as we
try to make the next right good decision
if you want to be on the show we're
talking about mental health we're
talking about emotional health we're
talking about uh marriage relationships
dating kids whatever you got going on
pets I don't know a lot about pets but
uh
I'm happy to laugh with you
um if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 or go to
John deloney.com ask
a-s-k and Kelly you're rocking the hot
pink earrings today well done it's
awesome thank you I've also have hot
pink heels on but nobody can see this
y'all wouldn't think that she matches
her uh earrings with her shoes but
that's how Kelly rolls I I think that's
fantastic and I just bought a guitar
that looks exactly like your earrings oh
you ended up with a hot pink one and it
is it's incredible we had discussions
about like a Camo versus hot pink and I
was I was uh very much championing the
hot pink it uh my seven-year-old
daughter's eyes lit up so I'm very
excited
and I'm glad that I have a guitar that
matches your earrings that's one of my
life goals that I can check off you can
borrow them anytime you like
I actually still have the holes in my
ears from my the when that was cool
which guys it's not cool it's just not
cool it's just not cool all right let's
go out to uh Raleigh North Carolina and
talk to Dan
the man what's up Dan
hey how are you sir outstanding brother
outstanding outstanding so man uh what's
happening
uh
again let me let me practice this by
saying I know I'm not the good guy here
uh I'm just trying to
you know figure out how to how to get my
life back
cool tell me what happened man
um about a year ago I entered into an
affair with someone at work okay and
um blindsided my wife
and moved in
uh with another woman
and
for this last year
uh you know we found our ups and downs
um we've had some communication issues
and a lot going on
uh now uh we'll get that now but
ultimately she had a child uh it was
just a year over a year old
and I raised this child
I like my own and the
you know the father was in the picture
uh he's a he's a good dad he's there
um but it's
it's caused some issues in the fact that
around Christmas time uh we decided uh
that we wanted to do on Christmas
um because I saw how having two separate
thanksgivings you know it just and
devastated uh
and devastated the mom
and uh
ultimately he he never left he sort of
just moved in and then we made it
official so it was me
uh I guess my girlfriend and
the father of her child Under One Roof
along with the toddler and
there was always you know some friction
there that guineas that he was a nice
guy
um but you know it was just a very weird
dynamic
you think
yes
like there had to like there had to have
been a point when you were thinking like
just sitting on on the toilet just
scroll on Instagram you were like
is not a great idea
yeah well you know I'm I'm not big into
social media I stay away from that well
good God Almighty you know what I'm
trying to say like at some point you're
like this is a terrible idea so was your
wife I mean I'm sorry it was your
girlfriend
I mean were you all like a like a
throuple we all all in this together or
was she dating two guys or uh she was
she was just dating me but no way no way
of course she hooked back up with him no
no no uh it was it was very weird but it
wasn't it wasn't like that
um
she you know he had a lot of debt and he
didn't have anywhere else to go really
and she didn't want to take time away
uh from him with his child or at least
that was her thought process there was
no thinking going on at all but okay so
bring me to bring me to now
yeah yeah
um so let me let me just let me just
recap so
you're married how long were you married
in August of last year so at seven years
you you bailed and moved in with
somebody
um that at work so you you had met
somebody at work you fell in love you
you choose your girlfriend you moved out
on your wife just blindsided your wife
moved out did you divorce your wife or
did you all just get separated
uh we are currently separated okay so
you're not officially divorced
correct why haven't y'all why hasn't she
filed on you or you and her
well we're doing a simple divorce so
we've been a year apart and then
uh it should be a pretty simple process
for that because no one's trying to get
any anything from anyone oh I forgot
North Carolina's got some of the
stupidest rules when it comes to that
crap
um so uh
foreign
so then you move in with this woman and
you have normal relationship issues and
probably some good times and probably
some what in the world times and she's
got a one-year-old and then at
Thanksgiving
um there's two different thanksgivings
and then you're like let's not do that
at Christmas and so
baby daddy comes to stay for Christmas
and then just like Moves In
yes
so then what
that obviously you know cuts down on the
intimacy Factor no no it doesn't
yes it does believe it or not no way no
way and I
um
you know
I I feel like I
have done everything I possibly could to
to make it work
um I I basically changed
you know I
everything I didn't do before I'm I
tried to emphasize
me doing and it was an extremely
rewarding experience but you know every
every day I woke up I I knew that if I
had tried that hard
with my wife
you know I wouldn't be in that position
why'd you leave your wife
um
well
I say this at the time because I have
you know hindsight
of me just being a
um why'd you leave your wife
she
um said you know she wasn't sure she was
really a Believer anymore
okay and
she said she would
actually wasn't really sure if she
wanted to have kids
anymore okay
I'm glad
I mean that's what I told myself at the
time but
it was really
you know
I just I didn't feel like I mattered
she was she was locked in
oh sorry all right you're all right man
you're right shake your breath talk
directly into your phone for me I want
to make sure we get all this
um
I just didn't feel like I'm at it it
didn't matter if I
it was there or not
um I mean she she had it
she's a thousand times smarter than me
by the way obviously
um so that's what that's what I told
myself
so this happens over time
and the whole time or at some point some
point during this time
there's a co-worker that's hilarious
kind of pretty at first and gets more
pretty over time and
I wouldn't believe do what
like you wouldn't believe John yeah last
at your jokes
um puts your hand on your shoulder when
she's telling you a funny thing or on
your forearm just little gentle things
like that and
you suddenly for the first time in a
long time feel that terrifying feeling
of alive again
yes sir
and then you can look back at your home
life and come up with any number of
reasons why this is the right thing and
what you've been doing for the last
seven or eight years is the wrong thing
yes
um yes
so you've been you've burned through a
year you know that's a mess
and now what
so a few weeks ago a couple weeks ago
I as she asked me uh my girlfriend text
me hey do you want to meet
um at a place uh Carey it's a local town
over here
um and I say sure and I I go over there
and we go into the Whole Foods to get
some snacks you know it's not unusual
for her to do this kind of thing where
we just have a little picnic
and we go over because they have a
little play area
where the kids can play it takes me over
there and she says
I can't do this
um because at least was coming up uh it
was it's expiring so I can't move to a
new home with you
uh
I can't live with two men I'm not
married to anymore and I can't take time
away
from the father of my child's
like a kid take time away with from him
and his son so
that's uh
I uh
so you got dumped
I I don't and uh you know in a split
second I lost uh
everything I had yeah and uh
was blindsided and obviously there's
some kind of
larger humor here for everything I did
to someone yeah
I think Alanis Morissette saying about
that right yeah
how can I help you right now man
I know you're hurting yeah I woke up
uh the next day
at a rest homes and not a rest home like
a rest area I'm not that old
but rest area and uh I've never felt
more alone in my life
not a single time
and
I just didn't know what to do
so
I uh
I texted my wife I was like hey
here's what happened
um you can track me now on Google Maps
just uh keep an eye on me if you don't
mind
and then I asked if she wanted to just
meet up to talk later and she said sure
she she responded immediately
and uh she was you know since that she's
just been an absolute rock for me again
and
I don't know what to do
I just called my life backs whatever
whatever that looks like I want to be
okay
I think you can be okay
the life you had is over
and the longer you try to
pretend the last year didn't happen
the longer you try to avoid the fact
that you ripped some woman's heart out
the longer you try to
not feel the fact that your heart just
got ripped out
that's a recipe for disaster down the
road
it's grief it's heartache it's shame
it's all of that
and if you try to run past this and try
to over like end around this thing it
will haunt you
physiologically this is not just woo-woo
this is neuroscience it will haunt you
there is no going there is no going back
the beautiful thing is you can build
something else
uh I think when uh you know a year ago I
sort of just buried myself in my work
and you know pouring myself into
my girlfriend and this child
and you know I don't I don't want to
bury anything this time good
but
I this is just me and you're a grown-up
and your wife's a grown up
um
I'm talking to you as though you and
you're one of my close buddies I would
tell you she doesn't
you don't get to just run back to her
and say my bad
now she may love you forever and be
willing to take you right back and all
that I don't even know if that's what
you're asking
um
but I think you're going to be
responsible for
well
then you'll be responsible for a couple
different things number one
you've got to be responsible for your
healing
and of course you're worthy of being
loved but right now you may not be
worthy of dating or being married to
and you may have a lot of work to do on
becoming marriage material becoming
romantically involved material has
nothing to do with your lovability in
your intrinsic worth as a person
do you see the difference there
yeah
if your wife was my close friend I would
tell her to be very very careful with
you
because you just had your heart broken
and You're vulnerable
uh I mean even looking back a couple
weeks ago I just feel like it was so
selfish of me to contact her at all no I
mean it was but you're also it's selfish
to I mean I guess it's technically
selfish if you're drowning to scream at
somebody
you know
in the Lifeguard stand and say help me I
guess that's inherently selfish because
I don't want to drown but that's the
right thing to do
I think that's a good signal to you that
you've got to be about the business of
making friends
and getting some community in your life
and getting some accountability and some
men in your life that you trust that can
speak into your life
and possibly not possibly a hundred
percent before the day's over calling
and getting a counselor or a therapist
in your community
and I know there's some great ones in
Raleigh North Carolina
a dear friend of mine
pastor
I I called him too and I met with him
last week and I'm meeting with him
uh in a few hours today so okay but
listen he doesn't get to be your
therapist he gets to be your friend
yeah he gets to refer you and you have
to be very intentional about asking him
I need referrals to professionals
um because I need you as my friend
what does that mean he needs to hold the
right to call you really stupid like
what you're doing is dumb or what you're
doing isn't healthy or get off the couch
we're going running or whatever we're
going to the gym right now he needs to
preserve that
and you need to go do hard therapy with
a professional therapist and there's a
powerful different difference
okay yeah
and you've got to hear me there is no
going back you don't get your old life
back it's over
it's over foreign
what are you going to build next what
are you going to build moving forward
and it's going to take a long time
that's not something to be scared of in
fact it's the opposite it's something to
settle into it's gonna be a bunch of
tiny decisions that you make every
single day they're going to start to
create new habits they're going to start
to create new ways you see the world and
experience the world and think about the
world and the world thinks it
experiences you
and then you're going to make some major
changes
and I think
um
if you haven't already I think there's
something very important not for
something back
not for an Roi
but you may have gotten a glimpse now
and I only think it's a glimpse because
you were playing house with somebody for
a year and also with her other boyfriend
who she had a kid by that whole weird
thing
you got a glimpse
of the pain your wife experienced
just a glimpse
but I think there's something about
getting down on your knees in front of
her and saying
how gut-wrenchingly sorry you are
and maybe this divorce continues on
maybe I'll find reconciliation down the
road that's not a today conversation the
today conversation is
I need to take a knee before the woman I
promised my life to and let her know
I hurt you so bad I'm sorry
and my mission in life is to become a
man that will never hurt somebody like
that ever ever ever again myself
included
I think you can do that
I wouldn't do the show if I didn't
believe in that sort of restoration but
it's gonna be tough you're gonna have to
be very vulnerable and very honest and
most importantly you have to do stuff
you've never done before
in terms of telling the truth and
letting your needs be heard
and I'm not this isn't a place from I'm
not gonna beat you up on the show
I know you're hurting bad right now
I know you're hurting bad
don't give up on you man
uh we'll be with you every step of the
way hang on the line and I'll miss you a
copy of all your past change your future
stay on the line Jenna we'll send that
to you just my treat if I can help you
anyway brother holler at me okay
today when you go talk to your body say
I need you to be my friend moving
forward I need some references because I
got some hard work I got to do a hit
and then call that wife yours sit down
take a knee say
[Music]
sorry
that level of vulnerability that's
that's the soil that we'll start
planting new seeds in we'll be right
back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to San
Antonio Texas and talk to Kendra what's
up Kendra
I'm partying we are doing great so
what's up how can I help
I have a question about how to deal with
survivor's guilt oh what happened
well I am a 10 on the Asus score holy
smokes my I came from a very very
abusive childhood uh my mother had a
something or drug problem okay
um make myself and three other siblings
and
I am are you the one that made it
yes I am
8618 days sober congratulations wow
Kendra
that's amazing
but it's hard knowing that I am the only
the old arrived I know
are your brothers and sisters still
alive and hurting
uh they're not
um
my sister Melissa
uh odina 99 uh my brother Josh OD'd in
2001. and I have another brother that
OD'd in 2014. good God almighty
you guys lived in hell didn't you
we did
what was your path out
um
determination
I was determined
um
when I was 15 I got pregnant with my son
Luke
um my son ended up I ended up being shot
when my son was six well it went through
my leg killed my son
um that's when I wrote my sobriety
because literally the day that my son
died I wanted to die yeah
um
I had a very very
lovely woman his grandmother who
said not on my watch
it's not gonna go down like this
um and she literally held me hostage for
three days to get me clean again
oh because you were you were heading out
huh I was I was done yeah
I've been sober ever since she had a
massive stroke about two years after I
got clean
and I have pretty much any time I
remotely think
their life's not going the way it needs
to
I hear that woman squirts in my head
she's your guardian angel isn't she
definitely is
you may have heard you may have heard me
say this on the show but
um
there's a great conversation years ago
with somebody who'd been to parts of the
world where there was just Mass
Slaughter of people and they asked a
pastor there how do you still believe in
God with all of this death and
destruction
um
and Where's God in all this and the
pastor looked at him kind of cold and
said oh I stopped asking Where's God a
long time ago I started asking where's
God's people when did they show up
and I don't know if this person was
religious or not but this is one of
those holy moments when somebody
saw you and took you and said not on my
watch
even she was definitely religious she
was
the most devout Catholic southern New
Orleans woman you would ever meet in
real life that's one of my favorite
people in the world to be around
because they can out cook you and out
swear ya and out Bible yet all at the
same time so the people are amazing
exactly
all right so
what happened so that you're talking
you have experienced and seen can I how
whole are you right now can I be pretty
specific for our listening audience
I don't want to melt you here on this
call but I want I want them to to have
some sort of picture about what you've
experienced
I have no grown kids I have a seven
month old grandbaby I am working 90
hours a week for like trying to
be out of that and change my
generational
drama
um
but I'm not working I am trying to be
working
like I am burying myself
and working because if I'm not working
my mind goes I don't deserve okay
you don't deserve this beautiful healthy
grandbaby
you don't deserve two grown kids that
have turned into relatively all right
adults are they relatively all right
adults
I have one that graduated two years
early I have another one that graduated
with honors I I I don't know as a single
mom how I ended up having
so amazing
kids I'll tell you
you want to hear it
what's one of my core principles on this
show
I will never lie to you
I'll tell you exactly how two amazing
kids made their way into the world and
grew into two amazing functional adults
because they had a gangster of a mom
foreign
and that doesn't mean that Mom didn't
need somebody to grab her by the hair
and keep her alive for three days
she held her baby boy she bled out right
in front of her
that doesn't mean you didn't need help
along the way
and that doesn't mean you got real lucky
sometimes
but it does mean
that they had a mama that changed their
family tree
I'm definitely trying no no honey
you clawed through concrete to create a
new path for those kids and you did
here's the ugly thing about survivor's
guilt tell me if I'm if I'm on to
something okay
there's usually I call it the haunting
there's a couple of things that haunt
people with survivor's guilt the first
thing is I should have or I could have
should have gone back for brother and
sister I could have gone back and done
this if I had just done this or if I had
just done that is that there every day
okay that's number one
it is absolutely Stone not true
okay
you have escaped a
nuclear reaction and the Temptation is
to go make yourself into the hero that
could have walked through radiation and
all of the blast fall out to rescue
people and that simple you could you
couldn't have done it it's not true
that's number one
number two you're haunted by being on
the outside of your tribe and this
sounds crazy to people who hear your
story they're like you have an Asus
score a freaking 10. like
that means you literally lived in hell
and
every loved one you have around you has
died
and
it doesn't make sense but you left your
tribe in order to survive and there's a
part of you that says but those are my
people
Fair
definitely fair People Like Us don't
sleep through the night and hold healthy
grandbabies
People Like Us don't work 90 hours a
week we just get checks in the mail
People Like Us have to steal the last
two and a half weeks of the month
because we smoked the other half or we
snorted the other half or we pulled out
the other half
Fair
very fair
so sometimes survivor's guilt is a proxy
pain
for
disconnection from what feels like our
roots
because of those kind of people are the
ones that have Healthy Families we are
the kind that burn this thing to the
ground
and the third one is the haunting is the
question that is is the worst one I
think because it has no answer
and that is why me
like how in the hell did I get out
why did I get picked well I gotta carry
all this stuff
absolutely and why does every day
feel like I have to fight for it
so let me um paint you a different
picture with that question why me I I
understand that question intellectually
and understand that question in my soul
but I have to be honest I gotta own
reality that there is not an answer to
that question that I'll have on this
side of being alive
if my faith believes her right maybe
I'll get an answer to that on the other
side but I ain't gonna get that here the
question that's more important is what
am I going to do now
what am I going to do with this gift I
don't know why I got it I don't even
want it and it's hard to carry
it's real real heavy because inside this
gift also is
The Haunting of my brother and my sister
and my baby boy and my mom even my dad
my dad was evil but even my dad
they're all in this thing and this
sucker's heavy to carry around right
you still there
I am okay
everybody I have to
choose happiness
and sometimes it's harder than others I
got you
and then when I come up on birthdays or
anniversaries or
that's when it's hardest
because how come I get another birthday
and they don't
so can I give you permission just to be
real sad
on those days
here's what I'd love for you to do I'd
love for you to write them a birthday
card and read it to them on every
birthday and every anniversary
or write them a letter
about all the cool stuff they're missing
and let them know how much you miss them
and let them know how pissed off you are
that they're not here
let them know all of it
how cool this little grandbaby is
if you feel that sense of guilt and that
sense of sadness and sense of
broken-heartedness that they're not with
you they didn't get out to
and you run from it
that fire will eventually overtake you
to
but if you will turn and walk directly
back through that fire you're going to
find out it's not burning anymore
and you're gonna find out the ghosts of
your brothers and your sisters and your
baby
are still there and you can write them
letters and you can tell them I miss you
and you can tell them I'm living my best
damn life for you
and what you're going to find is in five
years and seven years
you're gonna accidentally forget one of
those birthdays not because you're bad
not because you're you have no character
and you can't believe you forgot
because your body has finally let them
go
they can finally go rest
because right now you're dragging them
around right
every day yeah
it's time for them to go
time for him to go and I know that's not
an easy thing it's going to take some
time
but I do think it's worth your time
writing them a letter and every time
your son's birthday comes around
you let your family know mama's gonna be
sad today
I'm not gonna do anything destructive
I'm not gonna hurt myself I'm not going
to use again
but I am going to write my son a letter
I'm gonna take myself out to some sort
of meal by myself
or I'm gonna throw a party I'm gonna do
whatever you want to do
other boy's gonna be part of you for the
rest of your life
we gotta stop asking the why me question
and we got to start asking with a smile
on our face and some Adventure in our
heart what am I gonna do now
how am I going to
live the funnest most adventurous most
beautiful Reckless
generous life I can
because they didn't get to
that makes sense
instead of it being something that
weighs you down it becomes jet fuel and
what comes next how old are you
I am
you're a 44 year old grandma good gravy
Kendra you're not even halfway done yet
the Kendra party's just getting going
have you gone to see a counselor
um
I've been in a counseling for the last
20 years
are you done with it
with counseling no okay
I just put it on pause because I'm
trying to pass my house because nobody
in four generations has ever owned a
house how close are you 38 thousand
dollars
until your house is paid off so my house
is paid off I will be completely dead
free and thirty eight thousand dollars
how long is that going to take you I
know you already have that date circle
on your calendar how close are you three
years and two days
if I don't value
I I I Can't Describe to you how amazing
you are
and I know that doesn't make you feel
better and that doesn't take away what
happened to you and your little girl and
that doesn't take away your lost baby
boy and those images in your mind I know
but there's that great Terry real quote
that I just love
which is
the family trauma rolls downhill like a
forest fire generation to generation
until one brave soul turns and stares it
down and says this stops with me
and it brings peace and laughter and joy
to Great grandkids that you will never
meet
it also means that the person that stops
and stares down a roaring forest fire
gets burned and scarred along the way
and that's the position you've chosen
and generations will tell the story of
Grandma Kendra
because she said no more
she said no more
the healing path out if I'm if you're my
sister or if you're like sitting down
having dinner with me here's what I
would tell you
you gotta systematically start writing
these folks letters that you lost
and let them know how you're doing
and it's different than praying it out
or just speaking it out when you're
mumbling around the house or when you're
outside in the backyard having a
cigarette you got to be able to write it
down and get out of your body okay even
if you don't spell well if you're if
your handwriting's off I don't care any
of that stuff
but I want you to get a nice notebook
and write it down
in the next birthday that comes up of
somebody that you've lost I want you to
go to the store and buy a birthday card
spin the four bucks on it I know you're
trying to pay off that do it anyway
spend the money on it and
I want you to have some sort of private
ceremony for them okay and then the last
thing is you got to got to got to
get on the phone they're in San Antonio
I know there's some incredible providers
here in the state of Texas because I I
know them personally
and I want you to get on and go find a
trauma counselor in your area
and say I'm ready to fully set this
childhood down
set it down and they might get with a
medical provider because you might need
some the aces stuff there's there's
medical complications that come with an
Aces score of a 10 just over a lifetime
heart issues and blood pressure all that
kind of stuff so I think sitting down
with the doctor and saying hey I'm gonna
slow down my
uh maybe this is a good example so if
you're watching
um NASCAR
and they're hammering it on that
straightaway and they're going 250 miles
an hour however fast they go I don't
know how fast they go and they start to
make a turn they have to slow down to
make that turn
so that they can stay in the race and
get to the next straightaway and Hammer
it again
I want you to think of the next couple
of months going to see a doctor going to
see a trauma counselor it's going to
cost you money you have to slow down you
have to miss a couple of shifts and it's
going to slow down your progress what
you're doing is making a turn because if
you just keep going this hard in three
years you're gonna have a paid for house
you're gonna be dead on the front porch
and that I don't want that for you I
want you to pay this house off you're
gonna be 50 years old you're gonna have
the house paid off and unless you sit on
that front porch being a crazy grandma
Kendra to those grandkids
and letting your your grown kids go have
hot dates with their
husbands and wives or whatever is going
on in your world
but I want you to slow down for just a
minute and make that turn you're going
to find out that when you make that turn
and you get healthy both
emotionally and psychologically and
physically it's gonna make those
straightaways even faster than you can
imagine
it's gonna feel like you're slowing down
and you're stopping but it's not it's
just re-gearing okay it's just making
the turn
it's being smart and being safe so that
you can hit it on the way out
[Music]
talk to a lot of brave people it's my
job I talk to a lot of courageous people
a lot of people are making some turns
and you my friend Kendra are at the very
very very top of that list
so so proud of you
I can help you in any way holler at me
okay I'll be with you every step of the
way when you pay that house off
um you're giving us a call back because
you're gonna do that debt-free screen
we're gonna you're gonna hear me
cheering all the way from Nashville
Tennessee
thank you love we'll be right back
all right we're back let's go to Albany
New York and talk to Ava what's up Ava
hi
what's up
um living the dream
anyone who says they're living the dream
is like for sure not living the dream I
I hope you are living the dream I hope
it's I hope your life is dream worthy
what's up
um can't complain uh well my question is
you could but then you'd be Kelly so
there you go
all right go ahead um my question is uh
what are some considerations when you
are putting together a will as far as
who will be the guardian of our children
um huh tell me more
so um my husband and I have uh two small
kids they're four and five and um we we
don't have a will yet I know we needed
two years ago sorry years ago but um
today today today today get one okay yes
I yeah
um but how do we pick a guardian
um so I always thought my sister would
be the guardian of our kids we're pretty
close
um but she
you know now has children of her own now
she has a newborn and a two-year-old and
I just I feel like if anything were to
happen to us you know I'm gonna add my
kids who are all close in age two and
you know is that going to be more of a
burden or have you asked her I don't
know
I haven't asked her now ask her you're
spending a lot of time in your head this
is where a lot of people get stuck
because the the the thought of their
kids waking up
I'm gonna get real graphic right now is
that okay
yeah yeah I'll use my kids because it'll
be easier to metabolize the thought of
my son
opening his eyes
and getting hit by that dump truck
of pain
knowing mom and dad are gone
I cannot wrap my head around that
I don't have a picture in my head of my
kid of my daughter
getting up and stumbling out of her room
into the living room and work on
or I know I I have a picture of what her
body posture would be if she walked out
of a strange room down a strange hallway
into a strange kitchen and some other
adults were in there even adults she
knows and Mom and Dad are gone I know
that picture
and I hate it and I don't want it in my
mind
right
yeah it's easier to not think about but
I know it's something that we have to
you know yes Ashton have a plan and
because if you don't you're just
suggesting not suggesting you are saying
to the state of New York we would prefer
that y'all make this decision not us
and
I live in New York but from afar I
wouldn't put a ton of trust in that
government at this moment
nope all right
so
um and that's not even just goes for New
York that goes for any state government
so we're faced with I don't want to
imagine this
and so when we don't want to imagine
something we get in everybody else's
head around us and we create stories in
their heads
and ends up shutting us down we end up
not moving forward we won't do anything
so step number one is ask your sister if
that's the person that's the person
here's a couple things I'm going to look
for number one
um
I want values to be in the in the in the
neighborhood right
they might go to this church over this
church but if you want your kids raised
with a certain
um Faith tradition that needs to be a
part of it right also knowing that their
faith tradition may change when they're
15 or 16 or whatever or the people
raising your kids might change just like
yours might change that happens that's
life you can't predict every variable
out but I also want people that I've
seen have their own kids
and they're doing pretty good job at it
like I like how they raise their kids I
like how they handle conflict I like how
they don't freak out or they don't yell
or whatever the thing is
the third thing
um
and
this one's this one's tougher um and I
might be in the minority on this one and
so if people want to make comments make
comments about me not about you Ava
um
but I want people in my local community
that my Ki it will minimize the
um it will minimize the transfer to my
kids what does that mean
um my family is all in Texas my closest
friends in the world are all in Texas
uh if I lived in Texas and my friends
and I who they're over at my house all
the time and my family who's around it
would be a no-brainer that my kids would
go with one of them
but now I've been in Nashville Tennessee
for five years
that world is foreign to my kids they
don't know those people like I do they
don't have those long-term relationships
it would be terrifying and
tragically uprooting to pick them up
from everything they know in terms of
sidewalks and schools and grass and
weather and drop them in the middle of
y'all just go do life there
and so we worked really hard to find
people in our local community that we
felt great about
and we asked them and they said sure and
we
probably every 18 months or so we
probably need to be a little bit better
about it but we re-up are we still good
does this still make sense for us me and
my wife and does this still make sense
for them
and if it is we let them know here's
where our will is here's what um our
financial situation will be and y'all's
financial situation will be and quite
honestly I don't have a ton of crazy
restrictions on it
because if they take my kid and and my
two kids they may have to get another
house they get my two kids they may have
to alter how they live and if I don't
trust them enough with my with my money
then why in the world would I trust me
with my kids
I guess that was like like a part of my
question is
um so yeah originally
also we all we have different personal
views on on money specifically
um uh so we like me and my husband we
have life insurance in place then
um yeah my husband brought up like wow
if we both die they're gonna get like
you know all this money and life
insurance like are they going to be
responsible with it you can put it in a
truck love my children but you can put
that money in a trust that would be
dispersed to your kids at varying ages
16 18 25 30 whatever
um and also there's a trust that would
disperse money to
your whoever takes your kids that's just
you sitting down with a with a tax Pro
but Kelly's talking to me hey sorry
suicide we've done this recently okay
um you can also we have someone that
takes our children you know should
something happen and we did the same
thing you did John
um it's not our families because our
families aren't local and they don't you
know so it's it's a local friend but
also somebody else has Financial
oversight uh somebody who I trust
implicitly who has the financial
oversight so any any expenditures in
anything from the trust would go through
someone else so that the person living
with them is not necessarily
get it for the money yeah so I I I I
know this I know that I trust the people
who I'm gonna leave my kids to
implicitly I also know
because of where I work and the work
that I do if you have I don't know what
your life insurance policy is let's say
it's two million dollars
I also know somebody holding a check for
two million dollars changes them
instantly right
so maybe having some sort of oversight
um from a third party
who would would oversee like well I I
can't give you a million dollars you
don't need a million dollar house now
suddenly um or we need to make sure this
goes to college education and this goes
to the wedding and this goes to a car so
however you all divide it up is great
however y'all however y'all break it up
and maneuver that's all well and good
but it's just you and your husband being
on the same page and letting them know
like Hey sister I'd love for you to keep
my kids we love
um we'd love for you to be the guardian
of our kids are you still in I know that
you've got two kids
um great hey grandparents we would love
for to put you down as the Guardians
um and hey best friends hey whoever
and give them permission to say yay or
nay and if they say nay okay great
they've got their reasons it's not
personal great so grateful that they
gave you boundaries they didn't just say
yes out of obligation and they're gonna
have to raise a couple of kids they
don't like so good for them they said no
awesome we're moving on or they said yes
fantastic then we're gonna have a
conversation about here's where the will
is here is how we would disperse any
life insurance money what that would
look like and like Kelly we have a third
party like uh like me and my family
here's a big chunk to y'all we also have
this money to trust however that works
for you and the trust has a custodian
too who makes sure that that happens how
are we all doing great just let them let
everybody be on the same page as though
you and your husband ran for a quick
date tonight to get coffee and y'all
were hit by a car
um
and I wish that it wasn't that cut and
dry I've just
had to tell too many kids that their
parents have died or I've had to tell
too many parents that their kids have
died over the course of my career and it
just happens it just happens
any tips on um it sounds like a very
young
growing up like hey out of the blue what
are you doing tonight and uh will you be
the guardian of our children it's just
that bluntly or any tips on how to like
bring it up or I would say hey I need to
have a a hard personal conversation with
you nothing bad's going on
um but this is Sister to Sister
okay or a friend of friend I think if if
I'm not mistaken I think
I texted
our friends here
and I remember thinking it was the
funniest thing because that's like one
of the most important decisions of my
entire life and I texted it to him
but we were going to get together and we
couldn't or whatever and they're like
what do you want to talk about and I
think I had made it kind of weird which
my wife says I do all the time on the
front end I think they were asking if we
were gonna like do if I they were
interested like a wife swap or something
I made it such a huge deal like all
right this is gonna be a huge deal I
know it's gonna be kind of weird and
y'all don't freak out and so I think I
overdid it on the front end and but then
we couldn't get together for some
something happened and I ended up
texting him and I remember sitting there
going you should be ashamed of yourself
you just texted that but here's the
thing it gave them and it gave them
permission to not make a weird face in
front of me it gave them permission to
be like no and then come around to like
no this is actually pretty awesome it
gave them permission to do that so um
maybe if you if you need to say hey I'm
going to send you a letter the letter is
going to be weird
just let me know
and I'll call you in a week after you
get this letter if that's more
comfortable for you cool there's
something about letting people digest it
I don't need an answer right now
um maybe an answer in 10 days in two
weeks but we need to get this ironed out
we haven't done this yet and it's really
important
um
and go from there and be prepared they
may not ask you to keep their kids on
the back end that's fine they've got
their reasons it's all good
how does that sound
that sounds good I mean it's just yeah
none of this is fun if you enjoyed this
process you should probably go see
somebody
right if you enjoy making plans for how
your kids are going to navigate the
world when you're dead if that's fun for
you
you listen to a lot of murder podcasts
okay here's the here's the last thing
I'll throw out there
the Temptation is to try to mitigate
every variable
here's the hard hard truth
if two parents if were to die if me and
my wife were to die suddenly
and left my seven-year-old little girl
and my 13 year old little boy in the
world to make their way
even with the most extraordinary
Guardian
they've been thrown into the dark sea
for a while
and so to think on this side of that
level of trauma that I can mitigate
every variable and every if then is
nonsense it's a waste of energy it's me
exerting false fake control over a
situation that I won't have any control
over because I'll be dead
and so there is an element of trust to
this process there's an element of I'm
going to insure myself to the hilt so
that there is no Financial concerns when
they're in the middle of the ocean
trying to tread water I'm going to make
sure they've got men and women around
them that love them and are see the
world in their best interest
so when they're in their deep dark sea
and I'm going to make sure that I've got
um
that they know on a daily basis
starting right now
just how loved and strong and capable
they are
and really at the end of the day I'm
going to keep my hands open after that
I struggle with that I may uh type a
list maker checklist kind of person and
there is no list to be made if Mom and
Dad both go that's not true there is a
list it's a very it's a much shorter one
than you think than you think it is
right
um it's a much shorter than one than you
think it is
but good for you like good for you for
recognizing it you've got to got to got
to get a will
um and I'll say this when I moved to
Nashville I had a really extensive
um will made up in Texas I just happened
to be colleagues with one of the
greatest wills and trust attorneys on
the planet and um so he gave I mean it
was it was amazing and it didn't
transfer to a new state so I got with
Mama Bear Wills it's online company do
we have a discount with him guys
yes we do if you go on
ramseysolutions.com use code Dave's
deals okay at checkout you get 20 off
okay that's what I did that's what I did
for my family to bridge the gap between
sitting down and getting a full
financial plan and
I'm not having anything not having
nothing right so uh make sure make sure
make sure even if you go to mama bear
tonight and just say okay we got to get
something down because I die on the way
to work tomorrow which across this
country will happen I don't want to be
Debbie Downer but it will happen
I hope that none of the listeners on
this show God I hope none of his
listeners on the show but
you have to just go to Mom bear wills
and put that out there great and if you
want to get a more extensive trust and a
bigger Point all that kind of stuff
great do that set up those appointments
get that stuff knocked out but you gotta
get that stuff done done done protect
your kids protect your assets protect
your family protect your community
for the day not if but when you're gone
thank you so so much for this important
call Ava we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we head into the final
stretch of the show
of course we had to go with
the song of the day from the great
Alanis Morissette
songs called ironic and it goes like
this
an old man turned 98. and he won the
lottery and he died the next day
it's a black fly in your Chardonnay it's
a death row pardon two minutes too late
isn't it ironic
don't you think
it's like rain on your wedding day it's
a free ride when you've already paid
it's the good advice that you just
didn't take and who'd have thought
figures
starting a podcast
and then Kelly becomes your producer
a podcast about mental health and joy
and finding peace
and a murder podcast aficionado
isn't it ironic
don't you think
love you guys stay in school bye
[Music]